Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I
am your host for today, David Flanagan. Although
you probably and hopefully know me from across
the Internet as Rawkode.
Today is an episode of cluster. It has
been a few weeks since we've had a
Clustered, but I'm very excited
to have two great teams they work with
us to fix,
well, some unknowns.
And we'll get to that just in a
minute.
But I am on a new Mac, which
means I don't have any of my scenes
prepared, but, you know, I do want to
thank both of our sponsors, EquinixMail and Teleport.
So we use Teleport
every single week on Cluster. It's how we
give the teams access
to all the clusters using GitHub authentication.
It's very, very cool. And it's also what
we use live on the stream as well
when we're debugged. So we actually get shared
terminal access where we can all collaborate and
pair together, which is awesome.
So go check out Teleport by visiting Rawkode.link/Teleport.
And that keeps the sponsors happy and means
we can keep doing more episodes of cluster.
Also, all of the hardware that we use
for cluster, and then we go through a
fair amount of bare metal clusters here. We're
not doing things cheaply.
It's provided by Equinix Metals. So thank you
so much to Equinix Metals. You should try
it out. We have a $200
code.
Just use the code Rawkode.
And if you want to use that, go
to Rawkode.link/metal.
Simple.
That $200 will get you, like, anywhere from
a hundred hours, two hundred hours depending on
the instance that you use. I enjoy spinning
up the big, beefy ones, but you go
nuts. Do whatever you want.
Alright. Thank you to both of them, and
thank you to our teams.
No easy task getting people to join me
on a session and do live streaming of
fixing broken Kubernetes.
It can be stressful at times as much
as we enjoy it and learn and watch
and have fun. So I really wanna say
thank you to and
JetStack.
And we are joined now by team
Hello, team. How's it going?
Hey. Yeah. Good.
Alright. Could you please do me a favor
and introduce yourself? I'll I'll just little bit
about you, and then we'll get started with
this customer.
Cool. Yeah. I'm David Cullen. I'm a leading
staff solutions engineer at Jetfla.
Hey, everyone. I'm Peter Phillips. I am a
customer reliability engineer at JetStack.
Hi, everyone. I'm really happy to be on.
My name is Tom. I'm also a solutions
engineer
as well as David. We're working at JetSet.
So we're a consultancy working with working with
customers and doing Kubernetes stuff. More recently, I've
also been working in software supply chain security
and trying to sort of better understand that
space. So less time
breaking Kubernetes process as I was really good
at before. But, hopefully, today, can do a
little bit better and fix some.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, with that, we're gonna jump straight
to it. So I have my my screen
shared.
I have given everybody access to all of
the machines.
I'm going to open a session on crash
beer control plane one.
Please
look under active sessions and join the session.
And just so we we oh, I need
more faces on this. What am I doing?
It's been so long. I don't even remember
how it cost them.
Alright. I'm gonna do this ad hoc. If
you could all join the session, please.
Just type echo or anything like that so
that I know we're all on the same
page. That would be fantastic.
This is what I get for buying a
new machine and not having everything set up.
Okay. I get an access denied.
No.
Yeah.
Same goes for me.
But our faces are on the screen. So
well, we're we're halfway there. We're ready.
Alright.
We are running a new version of Teleport,
so I'm assuming I have also broken something.
So I'm gonna come into the JetStack rule.
I have given you access to all the
nodes. You have access to log in as
rich.
Looks fine.
Still an access to join sessions? Hello?
I bet this what that rule out. Okay.
I
don't know what to do. I'm gonna have
to fix this first aren't I?
So this is a good excuse to look
around teleport though.
Normally, just add so normally, I just update
the node labels which gives you access to
the window. Can you join this? Can you
open your own session and grasp your backup?
You wanna try that?
Do you get permission denied too?
Are we okay to enter his route? Or
Yeah. Go for it. Just I just wanna
know if that works.
Yeah. I got it.
Yeah. I got the same. Should be fine.
Alright. Do we want to join each other's
sessions rather than
Well, I'll tell you what. I'll join one
of yours then.
I'll join
David's.
But
I'm brute.
Come on.
I can't believe a custard custard.
Right.
Okay.
Test denied.
That was useful. Alright.
Let's
take a look at the
teleport config.
So simple, there's nothing to do here.
Alright.
So I'm going on to the cluster teleport
node. So this is
where everything is configured.
There's going to be,
won't be GitHub in here. It's okay.
But there's a join token,
please nobody join my cluster.
This must be a new change.
I'm not sure what to do.
I'm just going, why can I not join?
Teleport
join cluster
permission.
Because I must have been teleport have changed
the ACL, and there's a new permission for
this.
So
resources session.
We
need any of this stuff.
We don't need to press
join session.
Okay. Yeah. This is new.
Okay.
Don't bite.
Welcome to this episode of Clustered where we
turn the tables. Yeah.
I need I need a a
shiny name
for that's been teleported. It doesn't really work
with the telephot. Let's call it telephot.
Okay. So there is some sort of join
sessions thing here that I can apply.
When
clustered gets gets clustered. So
clusterception.
Resources session less than read.
Alright. We'll try like, I don't wanna spend
long on this, so we will try very
quickly.
And if we can't, I guess,
I'm just gonna be doing a lot of
typing and you're gonna be doing a lot
of talking or maybe one of you could
share your screen.
But let's try and fix it first. I
don't wanna be here. I'm gonna go to
role,
JetStack rule.
And we want to allow
that rules.
That gonna work?
Alright.
Now I don't know what's gonna happen here
if this is even going to work. But
could one of you just try and join
that session?
Yeah.
It worked?
No.
Damn it.
Okay. I am
I'm rude. That this is what I don't
understand.
The TCCL
users
get
where do get users?
Oh, wait. I'm not on my control.
Right. Let's try one more thing, and then
we'll have to come up with a backup
plan. Very sorry about this.
So from here, I can run TCTR command.
So I should be able to run get
users.
But let's do a YAML file
and modify all of our user accounts. Now
what is annoying is I am here
and I'm going to oh, actually, because I
don't use the normal rules. So let's do
auditor,
access,
and editor. These are the main rule and
I'm gonna do that for all users.
It's gonna be fun. So three.
Alright.
Hey. Well, if anyone wants to learn how
to configure Teleport, I do have a whole
bunch of videos on my YouTube channel.
So we've got this.
Roll.
Let's just search for rolls, shouldn't that?
Crash beer.
And we're good. Okay. Now we can do
TCTL.
I think it's update-fuser.net.
Or is it just update? I don't know.
Thanks.
I
remember how to apply the config.
Create
-fuser.yaml.
Alright.
Now we all have mega rules. Now I
don't think the rule permission is gonna work
right away, but you may have to log
out in back end. But, however, you should
hopefully be able to join my session because
I've given you access to pretty much the
entire house.
So let's go. Peace.
And if I don't see somebody typing in
the sessions, then I'm gonna cry.
No. I I don't think I've got access
still.
Nope.
So you can't join?
Unfortunately, not.
Do we do we think of this do
do we think at this point?
Did you log out? Did that have my
share screen? Or
I logged back out. Like, out and back
in again. It still doesn't work.
Yeah. Say Don't run that. I logged out.
Telepath internal join.
Access the name.
If I keep it,
it gives you everything.
Users,
rules, author access, editor.
Oh,
login is just wrong. Alright. Okay.
Last try.
Yeah. User. We've got this.
I'm not the one that's supposed to be
under pressure here. That's supposed to be
feel completely safe.
Alright. So
I think what I missed here is
logins.
So I think you've got the permission now,
but not for this user.
So I'm gonna pop all of this in.
Let's save.
Create dash f.
Alright. All the users have been updated.
Let's let's see where we are, and then
we'll just need to go up with a
backup plan if this doesn't work.
No. Did you log out back then?
Yeah. Logged out. Logged back in.
Damn it.
Alright.
Then backup plan.
I will be your typey typey.
Unless one of you wants to share your
screen, in which case, I'm happy with that
too. But otherwise, I am happy to type,
and we can work through that.
It's up to David, really, because I think
we we elected David as the as the
typist.
So it's up to him whether he'd rather
whether we rather we
instruct you or
Alright. Amazing. I'll do the type in then.
I've exported the kube config. We now have
the ability to run a kube control command.
Which one would you like me to start
with?
Oh, wait. I should've seen you're sharing your
screen. So I I can share your screen
if you want to do that. It's a
Yeah.
That's fine. Yeah. I'm happy with that. Okay.
Alright.
Seven.
Need to go to the game
Alright.
Can you zoom in and your font size
will be
perfect.
No. I got it. I got it. One
more.
K. Go for it. That's all good.
Cool.
Right.
Where do we start?
Okay. Nice. Do
do we have a CubeC panel?
No. Well, yes. But
Yeah. That's what I was about to see.
What are the permissions on QTTL?
We have seen this before on clustered. So
now I'm gonna find out who has paid
attention to the previous episodes.
Normally, do I
slightly mutable, but yeah.
But
your binary
does not have the executable bit.
That's
what it looks like to me.
Yeah.
I can't read it there. You can't chamad
the chamad. You can't you can't chamad with
the chamad. Yeah.
Do you know what I mean?
Hold on. I'm I'm I'm I'm frantically giggling.
Hold on.
Yeah. We we looked in our interviews
as well for some of our breaks.
We've
seen this on
clustered with team Red Hat and team Talos.
This
is a good break. Think this one.
So you could,
you know, you could use Perl
to do this. There is another way, but
Perl would be one option,
assuming they haven't removed the executable bit from
Perl.
That can also develop me. And you can
also Oh, yeah. That's a good one.
You can run the loader directly and pass
pass it the command you want to run.
I think we're on
Yeah. You could you can use l d
dot source to also execute
them on, which is what team Talos said
on the previous episode.
It's a great tech. I love that.
Alright. You've got a broken control player.
You
don't need have Too early for hints. Come
on.
Use the hints.
Oh.
So what was the error message? I I
feel like you you cleared that screen really,
really quickly.
Sorry. Yeah. I have a habit of that.
I actually have a ZHL plugin that clears
the screen after every well, before every command,
but people get complaining at me when it's
live streaming.
So, yeah, we got no containers on on
control plane.
Pay attention to the error message.
Yeah.
That sounds familiar, like, DNS
or data
things.
Trick into the request and succeeded.
No.
Well, you
run a PS, you get for a cube,
and the only thing you have is a
cubelet.
Yep.
Yeah. That looks pretty broken.
Container d.
Connect
from the fuse.
Focus there.
Switching off and on again.
That's exactly what it was about. Just
In fact, stop.
Think it's got something
more sinister going on.
It's happy.
Yeah.
Happy. Alright. Yeah.
Cool. Maybe not. I see stopping Pods, Sandbox,
and teardowns there.
This is a case that they're running something
that won't likely
stop it.
So we still don't have any Kubernetes component,
but container d looks like it might be
happier.
Do you still have error messages in the
log?
That was failing to speak to the container
d. Right?
No. We're we're getting the control.
Crash be a control thing.
Just that keyword.
Are any of the any other of the
error messages
ones that we should be looking at right
now? Or are we
I don't think there's any
just like an actual file system.
Do you see anything there?
Do we do a hint, guys?
I think that sounds like a good idea.
I guess we need that.
We will come from the.
So there was that
you're
you're very fast, but it says no log
left to log. And I don't see a
capacity warning
on your I think it was your log.
I did see something around the file system.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't
I think use maps. Are they alright? They're
fine.
The ones.
You send it to user.
Else can Is that CD running?
No.
Kubernetes, isn't it? So it would probably be
a container as well.
It should be a static manifest. Yeah.
Actually, Kubernetes is one of best.
I'll check-in the iNotes.
Mhmm. I've seen that one before. Yeah. That's
one of those ones that when the bungee
bungee good.
Yeah.
I had to recover from a % iNotes
saturation.
True.
That's fine now, though.
It does. That's free. As a I mean,
right now, my biggest concern is there's no
NCT.
You're not gonna get a working control plane
without it. Maybe start looking for HTTP logs.
Actually, one minute ago.
Can you do a quite detailed logs? Yeah.
Docker warnings? Mhmm.
Well, I think that is the log entry.
Log level info. I
mean, you can go to bar log containers
rather than using try control if you want.
It might allow you to search or
get a bit more visibility.
It's really gonna
Is there nothing in that entity fail?
No.
Nice.
Can also say they cleared the history as
well.
So
I thought I thought asking to look in
the history was cheating.
If people forget to clear their history, that's
a shame on them. That's perfectly perfectly illegal.
Alright. So that SCT log.
Is that all the Senate? Yeah.
So, like, something's limiting something's limiting the ability
to print logs to the file. Right? Which
am I right in saying that's what's causing
to error out?
Well, it's something causing
or is there some sort of maximum? Because
all the files are also four k, which
seems a bit This is well, this is
the thing. It's like I can you set
a a pod log limit?
The only thing is if
with with the pods all over, it meets
the limit, I don't know.
Ah, nice catch.
Where was this?
Sorry. I was And they could see their
new config. There's some sort of Okay.
Got you. Yeah. Yeah. The four k is
kind of I mean, you could just remove
that plugin's link altogether.
Yeah. Yeah. It's a good Or you could
remove that config. You actually don't need that
config with the container b.
So nice catch.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, we got queues there. Something is coming
up.
Wow. And it survived for more than eight
seconds. That's good.
Wouldn't you expect just just coming through a
container d noobie here, if if the log
size is set to be really small, would
you not expect the logs to just flush
and then keep going
in that limit in that limit
scenario?
Or am I naive for picking that?
I I don't know. I've never seen that
set in tweet before, so that's the first
time I've ever seen that. I wouldn't have
expected the containers to to stop, but I
guess container d doesn't want them I I
guess container d just says, hey. You're you're
too noisy. They shut the down. Yeah.
I have no idea. It's
something for someone to go find in the
docs and share in the comments. Yeah. I
know. Yeah. I just thought it'd be some
something interesting to consider for those that are
watching. So
Alright. So that error getting node error messages
typically means that Etsy is not quite or
it's not ready yet. Oh, there we go.
I think It wasn't
Yeah. I was
more worried that actually we haven't started up
in a
So this is like a health fair.
Woo hoo. And you have some pods and
an APIs there. Very nice.
Yeah. That break was interesting. I'm gonna have
to look that one up in the doc.
Yeah.
So
we just updated Docker image. Right?
In theory.
That's it? No. Oh, no. You don't have
a it's not ruled the pod.
So I
I'm gonna look on the work window. Just
just kinda put around on it.
How are we doing on the timer?
You've you've got plenty of time.
Okay. You
you've had a bit just under twenty minutes.
Good stuff.
Hold on. My light keeps going off. Bear
with me.
Yeah. My screen saver keeps coming on because
I'm not doing anything.
Let me disable that.
Right. So you modified the deployment manifest. You
changed the image tag from v one to
v two, but we don't seem to have
a new replica set being rolled
no new pod rolling out. Something is not
quite right.
Yeah. I think some
control plan being
not ready as well. It's got me somewhat
suspicious.
Yeah. You don't know. Haven't Can we just
restart the cubelets on the work?
It's not the worker nodes. It's the it's
the control plane
that we've just started up.
Okay.
What in here?
Think
it finds.
Oh,
if you do cube get events,
there's a warning for invalid disk.
That might be quite old, actually.
Yeah. That's probably the thing we've already made
so much.
Was unable to pull a new image because
of some capacity warning. It was, like, right,
or is it something else?
Because it's not even creating a new replica
set. So I think the image capacity is
a problem,
but I don't think it's the one that's
stopping the replica set being created.
At least not yet.
But how would you stop a deployment from
creating a new replica set?
I don't know. That might be given the
game away, but the the other team.
So
the change, what?
Well, can you run a get event on
the deployment
or describe the deployment to see the event?
Alright. So we can see is the image
definitely v two? No. It's v one. Right?
So your change hasn't
persisted.
Allocation revision to you, though. Yeah. But go
down there. Yeah. Your image is speed one.
The image tag?
Yeah. It's view one.
And then I'll remember that.
Nope. Not muted. Webhook.
That was my first thought as well, but
I kinda know.
Just to double check.
No.
Maybe
this is the image capacity.
Maybe it wasn't actually able to write the
change to x c d. To x c
d. Yeah.
Disk space looks good.
What
was it? The error message in drive disk
capacity.
Let's have a look.
You might wanna take a look at the
entity manifest,
see if anything's been changed.
Let's have a look at the schedule config.
But why are you thinking scheduler?
That's not the scheduler, though, is it? Deployment
is from control manager.
You were about about quick to jump out
of that
control or manage manifest, I think.
That doesn't look healthy, does it?
Yep.
Future resource log.
I think
no. I think I don't know if Tom's
talking to us or not. He's muted.
No. I was yeah. Someone came in quickly.
There
there are two things right there that that
have me because they're one,
I think entities are unable to to write
the rates. The fact that we don't see
v two tells me that that
edit we does as a deployment of this
just didn't work. And I think entities don't
know where to block that if it's not
for invitation.
Also, you dead x exit the API server
static manifest very, very quickly, and there was
I I think
you
think there was a change in there that
you missed.
Good.
Oh, was it the
controller manager?
Yep.
There we go.
It disabled the deployment controller.
Yeah.
Alright. But I'm still worried about that rate,
the NCT.
I mean, you could try adding the I
don't think the stable deployment controller would block
that rate.
I never I never saw anything in the
entity logs to say, like,
like, this this is the entity Okay. Entity
logs.
Yeah, I couldn't see anything related to that.
Still not seeing a replication set rep new
replica set.
I guess you could try, yeah, try and
edit it again. See if the generation does
that changes.
Yeah.
No. No.
Damn.
Alright. So what would stop
cube control edit from working?
I'm stumped too. I'll give you that. Can
we get it over YAML and use a
cube apply rather than
I don't know if that's gonna be any
difference. Yeah. Cube control edit does hide some
error messages, and doing a Q control apply
would definitely bubble those up.
And the remainder in the chat that there
are hints.
I think we're slowly creeping towards hint time,
if you want if you want my opinion.
Let's take a look.
It
is it possible that someone's messed with sorry.
I was looking to chat. Is it possible
that someone's messed with, like, the size of
of whatever disk that Etsy is writing to?
Would that
but I guess it would spare us for
that if
it run out of space. Right?
It would. Yes. But I think this hint
reveals
quite a lot.
We were on the hint.
So is your cube control actually talking
to the API server?
So, Watson, you're slash e t c slash
kubernetes
slash admin dot com.
That is the config correct?
Well,
I can see the patch through.
Oh, hang on.
Oh, 14728.
Is that what we see in the
I can see 14728141217Port6443.
Yeah. Yeah. It looks okay.
So now you're trying to look for
IP table rows to reroute traffic?
Yeah.
Not seeing anything. No.
Nothing. No.
I mean, are you familiar with malady?
Nope.
I am not.
It is an HTTP
proxy.
So
Why is that running? It's gotta be load
somewhere.
That looks okay to me.
Yeah. Good call.
API server.
Is
Is it the right API server?
Yeah. Oh, yeah. That's what I was going
through.
It looks it looks good.
Looks official. Are there any more containers listed
on that file?
No. No.
Interesting.
Joe in the chat suggesting there are more
deaths. I
was so sure there was gonna be something
binding on 6443
that wasn't the API server. Now I now
I feel like I don't know anything.
Have a look have a look at the
queue API server
and
pause for the load.
It's it's only in there.
Yeah. One container.
Otherwise
I don't think that's related.
No. But I can't get logs.
Oh.
I feel like
the patch requests are being dropped.
Can you run a
why don't you do a cube control, get
deployment,
cluster, and write the file?
Make the change and then do a cube
control apply dash f, but with v nine,
and then
see if we can see some of the
noise. And if not, we'll need to just
jump into some heads, I think.
We've got about ten minutes left.
Oops. Yep.
Because when you do the cube control apply,
it won't use the I thought it's like
it uses the patch bar, but I think
it gives you
let's let's see.
That looks better.
We used the patch, but it's a little
bit different.
Did it change it? Nope.
Was there anything in that that the output?
Like, scroll back up. Like, did we miss
something?
It says the 200.
Yeah.
Gen oh, wait. That response body still has
the old
generation.
Where's the image source? Yeah. Alright.
Oh, it's truncated.
Okay.
Andrew in the chat is suggesting you run
a get all all namespaces
to see if there's anything wrong in the
cluster.
Yeah. You got that.
Oh, apparently, you were close with the IP
table.
What is it?
I'm gonna take a hint.
I think are they suggesting to look at
NF table?
No. This is a new one.
Yeah. I think they're
so they're not using IP tables.
Ouch.
Okay.
I would just let's just see the next
tab. I'm really kidding. Let's just go for
it. Can
can can you can you literally
can you type literally NFT?
There is an NFT command available, but I'm
not sure what it does.
I'm not familiar with the NFT command. I
don't I I have no idea. I I'm
angry at them for using this just for
the for the sake of having to say
NFT repeatedly.
Yeah. I was thinking that.
What can you do? NFT less?
That's what I'm trying to find at the
at the moment.
It's magic.
Okay.
That looks
fine.
Yeah.
So I was a bit like
this rule set.
Oh,
hey. Hey.
List rule set.
Alright. How do change them.
I have no idea.
I know. I click Google's suggestion. You can
run NFT delete rule.
Flush?
So there's there's NFT flush. Yeah. Try a
flush.
But
then
Oh. Flush.
Hang on. How
about DPKG
dash p and tables?
I don't know if that would just remove
everything or not.
What was that again? Sorry, David.
Well, you can run n f t delete
real iNet
table IP net.
You can do n s t delete rule
or maybe rule rule set. I don't know.
And then
table IP net.
Yeah.
That sounds right.
Or try rule instead of rule set. Rule.
No.
Great.
Team crash beer. Can you tell us how
to delete this
Try
try NFT flush rule set. Just Flush. Just
that.
Hey.
That's that's something. At least I did something.
I've got nothing.
So
yeah.
Configured is good, maybe.
Yep.
Yeah. I hate I hate NFTs.
It's still it's a shock, really, isn't it?
Oh, they messed with IP tables as well.
Thanks.
I think it's saying it's
blocked.
Oh, they're saying run
IPtables.tnet.
So you have to list the NAT rules.
You still need list.
Just
flush the net,
Rose?
There it is.
Oh, yeah. Redirect
four eight five three.
You could just do an IP tables dash
t net dash capital f and just flush
them all.
Yeah. I was looking for the number output,
so I can never remember the
There's another one there, though.
You know, we say add dash b two
and dash a two to the graph, and
you'll get the extra link.
No number?
Pre reroutes.
How do we do the numbers?
You're right, though. Is this
can we just do IP tables flush?
You'll need to do a dash two there.
I should get rid of it.
Because then yeah. Anything like Selum and things
should put It they'll rewrite them. Yeah.
Alright. We
are out of time, but if you want
a couple of minutes, you I'll I'll give
it to you.
But I think dial diving into the RBAC
may require slightly more time. That's gonna take
80.
Alright. Let's let's look
at the rest of the hunts, see what
we've got.
Maybe it's okay.
There's maybe quite a lot still to debug
here. So I think we'll just leave that
there.
Alright.
I think we were so close.
Well Yeah. That's gonna take a long time.
Well, let's see.
You wanna tell us what what we missed?
Really?
Yeah. Hi. You did great. You had it
in the IP tables. It was like five
minutes into the session and you had IP
tables running and then you're always missing the
the correct chain.
We had a a man in the middle
proxy running who was applying a dry run
to every cube command you were running.
Where is the proxy running?
I thought that at the start on the
the cube control output actually showed the dry
run equals all. But Yeah.
Yeah. This is the thing. This is why
you shouldn't keep quiet in these scenarios. I
was gonna say, why is there a dry
run? But then I just didn't say anything.
Sorry.
Bad teamwork.
No. It's supposed to be You had it
almost.
And then we had the Rawk stuff. It
was just you had to work as a
different user. You had to use ads
and
work as a different group and user.
And the deployment
the missing deployment controller
you fixed already,
and I think that was it.
Alright. I got I got I thought that
deployed the
what is it? He was taking care of
you with the, yeah, the controller manager.
The dry run was a bit
messy. Yeah.
That that proxy was mean. Very, very mean.
Good fun. Alright. You if you had deleted
the pod,
the proxy had a problem. So it was
watching always
that the pod was removed, but then it
was stuck, but we figured you won't delete
any pods.
But you did Okay.
Thank you team JetStack. We're gonna move over
to the other cluster now. So feel free
to join us in the YouTube chat
and we will see you
later, but thank you. All right,
let's get this faded up.
Alright. User mean,
but a very good very good breaks there.
So you're you're very using malady as a
proxy. Right?
No. We were referring to this to this
communication model where you always have the eve
and Bob talking to another, and Mallory is
always the one eavesdropping or man in the
middle style.
But it was the same. You you you
have gave a great hint because Mallory was
intercepting the traffic.
Yeah.
Great. Well, let's see what JetStack have prepared
for you.
So because I have obviously got a broken
teleport configuration, I am kindly gonna ask one
of you to please share your screen.
And Yeah. I think I'll oh, I'll have
to
you'll have to use Google Chrome for screen
sharing. So, Joe, you're using Google?
Yeah. That's right.
Alright. Could you share your screen? I'm happy
to do all the typing and share my
screen if you would prefer,
and I don't mind either way. It's up
to you.
Do you have a preference?
I can try to share.
Okay.
Yeah. Restless. Has nothing here.
Next to the hang up button, so be
careful.
No. I only mute and hang up.
That's an option for to share a screen.
Alright.
I
could do the typing,
and we'll work through this together.
So let me close
the Oh, you give me a second, and
I'll try to get my GitHub login working
on Chrome.
And I'll fix all my stuff. Really need
to Restore
all the crew files from my old computer.
There we go. That's better.
Alright. So JetStack control plane.
Oh, we had prepared such a good script
for bootstrapping.
Okay.
I can run a script for you if
you want.
We'll
do it without.
Okay. So but maybe you wanna do the
completion?
Uh-huh.
Perfect.
Maybe you wanna alias
cube to k.
Okay. How would you like to test for
a control plan? What's up? Yeah.
Let's do it. Get pots.
No control plan.
Okay. So
let's see if are there any containers running?
Cryo CTL PS.
And
they are running.
Yeah. It does look like we have
controller manager scheduler. We just don't have an
API server. There's no API server. So maybe
the static manifests.
Is there a
yeah. Perfect.
There is one.
Man, what would you like to see?
Scroll down a bit.
I mean, it's interesting. Right?
The manifest is there,
but Kubelin is not picking it up.
Maybe
the
Kubelet
path for manifests
is not correct.
Yeah. Check that one. Maybe do a
systemctl
cut kubelet.
Okay.
So
there is the kubelet config is in varlib
kubelet config.
And then there should be a static port
something. Yeah. Okay. Kubernetes
manifests.
Is there a typo? No.
Nope. That looks
good. Okay.
We wanna check the the Cubelet locks?
Journal journal control,
a few yeah.
Cubelet.
Well, they can't speak to the API server.
And we just restart the Kubelet.
Sometimes
it helps.
Yep.
Okay.
But every other part is picked up.
Shall we check the logs for the API
server?
Yeah. I
can see that the manifest for the API
server is modified.
So if you run a list command to
the
manifest folder or manifest directory,
I can see a modified date.
Yep. It does look. It has been modified.
So this is probably the time where we
will have our backups from our cluster,
and now we are diffing the manifest files.
Well, I mean, let's go through it. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. All the flags.
Is there anything here
that worries you?
Is the secure port correct?
It is not.
Good catch.
Well, let's try.
Well, would that stop it from running?
No. This wouldn't stop it. Yeah. This is
not the case.
So the live, I think it's correct, and
the ready c is is
there as well. Yes.
The ports the ports are not right. Right?
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
And it's now?
Let's try it.
That's wow.
Okay.
Now the port should be fixed. Right?
Yep. And I don't think there's anything else
of particular interest in here. Although I am
worried about one thing, but I don't wanna
mention it yet.
Let's
write this.
Okay.
We have an API server.
So
And it appears
to stay. Let's
check pots.
Done again. No. The advertised address wasn't right.
Right?
It was a different advertised address.
It's 1065.
And in the
admin conf, it was,
I don't know, something different.
The annotation, you mean,
on the upper? So this is the Yeah.
I see
This is the yeah.
28141245.
Yeah. So that's the IPV 4 public address.
Yeah. And the other one is the private
one. Right?
Yep.
I think that should be
I think it should be okay.
And it is still running.
Do we have any cron drops? Oh, the
secure port actually is
Yeah. The sec the manifest was probably changed
again. Right?
Yep. Should please check the current jobs?
Let's confirm.
That's
yeah. Let's 443.
No. Check yeah. It was probably 8443
again.
Mhmm. Okay. Check the see Chrome.
Yeah. This is empty. All the Chrome there
are multiple Chrome
directories like ETC, Chrome tab.
Chrome d. Yeah. And
do I cut all?
That's something.
There is.
Remove it.
Alright. You're fine.
You're bad.
Okay. Now now we have to upgrade the
manifest again.
Perfect.
Alright.
It's pretty laid back if you don't have
to type anything.
Alright.
It's not restarted.
Alright. There we go. It's restarting.
No.
So the port is not not
But it's still six four four three, but
it's not
No. The kubelet can take a few minutes
before it does that. So we No. Restart
the kubelet. Yeah. Yeah. We can encourage that
along.
There we go.
Okay. Get pots.
Oh, wow.
But it's terminating. The POSCUS is terminating for
some reason.
Let's describe it,
the state four
set. It's the stateful set. Is it called
like that? No. Yeah.
Is there event oh, no. Events. Okay.
One desired.
So this the stateful set looks okay, I
think. But something is terminating it,
and something is preventing the clustered app from
starting, but that's maybe the missing Postgres?
No. I don't think it it will be.
Now, typically, in clustered in the past, when
we've seen things that are stuck and terminating,
it usually means that
if hand means our kubelet isn't alive on
the worker node.
And we run just kubectl get events.
Look. The notes are not ready. Oh. Yeah.
Okay. I don't think we have a kubelet.
Joe, what do you think? Should we call
in the the worker notes?
Or should we fix it on the worker
notes?
I guess we should fix. Right?
Yeah. Try to fix it. Okay.
Alright. Let's pop open Yeah. Just back. Worker
one. I'm assuming if we run a system
control
data,
we're just gonna see the kubectl is not
running.
Yeah. Okay. So but wait a minute. Is
it is it is is enabled? Yeah. And
it's failed. Okay.
Check log. So Yeah.
Yep.
Unable to load CA file.
We said JetSec had to mess with the
certificates.
We need a cert manager right now.
Yeah. Let's confirm, but I think yeah.
Oh god.
Is he there?
Or
What was it looking for? CA certificate dot
CRT.
It is. It is. Then maybe
yeah. So maybe but maybe it's the the
system d unit file. Maybe it's blocking access
to this
directory.
Yeah. Could you do a system CTL cut
Kubelet
service?
I think it's easier than that.
It looks okay ish right now.
It's all, or it was the complete file?
I'll leave that there for ten seconds. Hey.
Close attention.
Certs there are certificates.
There is a missing s.
Yes.
Alright. So I'll rename it on the, yeah,
on the file system.
XFL.
There's
no way to remove it.
Like I said, I should also see
template config. Or is this what the correct
name
There we go.
Okay.
But fixing one worker, I think is enough.
And we could cordon the other one, so
yeah. Thanks.
Do you need core node? Okay. No. It's
okay. Perfect.
Okay.
So get pots again.
Yeah. I think they're unfortunate that they're on
that that Yeah.
They just deleted.
Yeah.
Nothing bad ever came from deleting a Yeah.
No. I don't want dictation.
Uh-oh. Stop. Okay.
Let's describe it.
Temporal layer in name resolution. Okay. Same messed
up with DNS.
Okay. I guess I guess on the router
node, not on the control plane. Uh-huh.
Of course. Because the error is coming from.
Yeah. Okay.
So the host is the DNS on the
host is not working. Okay.
Let me check if the system d resolve
d is running.
Yes.
Could you do could you do a resolve
CTL
status?
Yeah. Red. Resolve.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
This
is
suspicious.
Those are the Equinix metal
DNS servers. Those those, I believe, are okay.
And we check on the master on the
control plane what's the correct DNS?
But it was an external d n external
IP. Right? It's the same. Yeah. The is
the Equinix method. So these one four seven
dot seventy five are Equinix method. So those
those are okay.
Yeah. Some IP debits.
Just drop drop to domain.
Yep.
Wow.
And
If you do the
dash dash line dash number,
I think or it was four maybe. But
Line numbers. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
What was that? Oh. Oh, I don't remember.
It's a chain output. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
It's gone.
Just to want to confirm, is is is
there additional drop rule?
Do we have a drop rule
on the control plane too?
Mhmm. But DNS was working on the control
plane. It was more broken.
Okay. There's at least another drop row too.
Okay.
Okay. So we had this DNS resolution. Right?
Yeah. Perfect. Okay.
Ta da. Running.
Okay.
Good. And more is pending.
So
describe the pending one.
Okay. Now we went.
Can we support?
Ah. Okay. But Oh, Yeah. No
scheduler.
The scheduling.
Could you edit the deployment? I mean, we
have to edit it anywhere.
Yep. What would you like to change?
We go with the v two first.
Yep. And, Joe, what do you think? Should
we do the node name?
We can try the node name Yeah. In
this in the spec. In the spec?
No.
It here? No. No. It's in the pod
template.
I guess it's in the Yeah. Yeah. Here.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, but, David, you have to remember the
name.
JetStack
worker one.
Okay.
Running. Are
we done?
Let's, yeah, curl it.
I can't remember the back. It's been so
long since I've got a cluster that I
don't remember the plus.
Sorry. Doesn't curl.
Version one.
Okay.
Let's see what's happened with the pod. Is
it version two on the pod,
the image?
Yeah. Already present on machine.
Maybe
we should Always.
Yeah.
It's
a
low image.
See, I can't I can't type. There's too
much pressure.
Perfect.
Alright.
This is a working method I could get
used to, so maybe I'll have to find
someone typing for me. Okay.
It's working. Question two.
But I would like to get into the
scheduler issue.
There should be a scheduler conf. Right? Yeah.
It is Kubernetes scheduler conf.
That's just authorization configuration.
Oh, yeah.
There's
basically, we are doing the same,
but
can we get the locks off the scheduler?
I just assumed that it's gonna be
I mean, you could remove the node name.
Right?
We could. Yeah.
But you want to do it and see
the logs. Right? So let's Okay. Let's do
that.
Actually
Peter, it was chat saying we should try
the actual video URL.
Okay.
Yes. It does.
Oh, wow. Beautiful.
So you have Okay. But have fixed it,
but we do there is something wrong with
the scheduler.
Yeah. You're thinking that the scheduler name is
probably not the default one?
You want to remove it?
Let's remove it and delete the pod. Yeah.
But if you if
you remove the default one but
now it's running too.
Mhmm. That's it.
Well, the time you absolutely smashed that.
I mean, obviously, it's because I was doing
all the tape and then I'm not Okay.
Alright. Well played.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Have a good one. This was cool.
Involve especially involving the the worker nodes, we
always thought about maybe, should we do something
with the worker? But then, I mean, we
we already had enough on the control plane.
But, yeah, nice.
And
no real certificate issues. Thanks a lot.
Oh, well. Welcome back, Pierre.
Hi. Hey, guys. Well done.
Let me pop you all back up. There
you go. Yeah. Good job, both teams. Those
were those were fun clusters.
Annoyed that we couldn't use Teleport properly. I'm
gonna have to work out with that, but
I will get that fixed with the next
episode for sure. But I hope you all
you all had fun. Alright? Perfect.
It was good.
Alright. The thing or two for sure.
Yeah. I was very impressed how methodically you
guys worked through the problem.
Yeah. That was we were both very, very
calm through that. I was just like, alright.
Let's look at this. Let's look at this.
You yeah. You just Yep. The good thing,
there was always an error message. And we
knew that the man in the middle proxy
we prepared, there was no error message. So
we thought, ah, this is gonna be hard
without an error. Yeah. That was very,
very sneaky. Where was the proxy running? Sorry?
The proxy was a bit hidden as well.
We hit the pit, and we named it
system d home d.
Oh, god. Yeah. But Yeah. It was never
we never wanted you to find the process
or kill the process because if you kill
the process, then the connection to the API
server wasn't working. You had to remove the
IP table.
And your proxy was dropping oh, no. It
was doing the dry run. Right? You were
injecting the dry run on film. Yeah. Yeah.
That is very sneaky.
I'll never forgive myself for not saying why
is there dry run-in that API request
in the first two minutes. I know. I
never said it either. I've seen it right
at the start. I just I just ignored
it because I didn't think it Yeah.
For anyone watching, it's a top tip is
why you don't say something because you think
it's gonna be a stupid thing to say.
Always say always say it even if it's
gonna be stupid in your head.
Mhmm.
Alright. Yeah. Well, thank you all for joining
me.
That was really two good two good two
very cool questions. So well done both of
you. We're gonna see David, thanks for the
for this
episode. Thanks for preparing everything.
I mean, I gave you all a broken
Teleport installations. I don't know why you're thanking
me, but
I just love that we get to have,
you know, clustered at all where we can
you know, I think that the way that
Kubernetes is still complex. Right? Like, we all
have to learn the hard way when it
comes to it, and it's always through trial
and error and a lot of pain and
sleepless nights typically that we learn how to
configure or just, like, why should anyone know
you can disable the deployment controller or the
or the pod controller? But all these things
do exist. And I think cluster is a
really cool way where we can just take
that knowledge from all of you and share
that with people that are watching. So, seriously,
thank you for joining us, and thank you
to everyone that is watching. This is what
makes trusted fun and what makes it work.
Alright. I'm gonna say goodbye to you all,
and thank you everyone for watching. I'll get
there's loads of, like, thank yous and awesomes
and thumbs up in the comments. We'll get
them all on screen as we say goodbye.
Thank you again to our team, thank you
to sponsors Teleport and.
Hopefully, it will be back where more custard
soon. So thank you all. I'll see you
all soon.
Bye. Bye, everyone. Bye bye. Bye bye.